[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo 26
minutes pour revenir sur l'actualité de
la semaine dans le département
au sommaire de cette édition la journée
nationale des sciences de l'ingénieur au
féminin s'est tenue ce jeudi 29 novembre
des techniciennes se sont rendus dans
les établissements scolaires pour
expliquer aux jeunes étudiants des
métiers de l'industrie
nous avons suivi les échanges dans un
collège d'elancourt 30e édition de la
journée mondiale de lutte contre le sida
36 millions de personnes vivent avec le
virus dans le monde
prévention dépistage accompagnement des
personnes séropositives et avancer sur
la recherche
nous ferons le point avec jérôme andré
directeur de hf prévention enfin dans le
reste de l'actualité
retour sur le lancement du portail de
signalement des violences sexuelles et
sexistes à guyancourt et sur le début de
la campagne d'hiver des restos du coeur
à trappes
mais avant de développer ses titres les
habitants de coignières sont appelés aux
urnes ce dimanche de novembre 2 décembre
par dont le second tour de l'élection
municipale partielle de la commune
le premier tour a placé en tête la liste
de didier fischer avec 48% des voix
suivie de la liste daddy bousselham
atteignant près de 39% des suffrages
arrivé en troisième position david
pelletier a décidé de se retirer à noter
que l'abstention a dépassé les 50%
ils étaient une centaine d'élèves ce
matin à bloquer l'entrée du lycée 17 mar
de maurepas les lycéens ont manifesté
devant l'établissement contre la réforme
du baccalauréat ainsi que le système de
parcours sur des pancartes brandies par
les futurs bacheliers résumer leur état
d'esprit
un des lycéens s'est exprimé au micro de
manon varaldo pour cette manifestation
contre la réforme du bac la suppression
des filières et des options moi
personnellement je suis un homme sur 5
heures je parle pour tous mes camarades
ainsi les soupçons trois heures c'est
une option qui nous prend vraiment à
coeur elle nous a fait nous épanouir
ça nous a fait rencontrer de nouvelles
personnes nous a permis de voyager
le sport c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui nous tient à coeur dans ce lycée
ensuite contre la suppression des
filières c'est pas forcément une bonne
chose
puis contre parcours sud c'est encore
plus médiocre son fonctionnement donc on
est moins ce soit plus facile pour notre
génération
à l'occasion de la journée nationale des
sciences de l'ingénieur au féminin ce
jeudi 29 novembre les élèves de 3e du
collège de la clé de saint-pierre à
elancourt ont pu rencontrer des femmes
ingénieures co organisé par les
associations elles elles bougent et hub
ch'ti en collaboration avec le ministère
de l'éducation nationale les élèves ont
pu échanger avec les professionnels
un reportage de manon varaldo savoir ce
qu'on veut faire pas toujours facile
pour des jeunes filles de troisième qui
parfois se mettent des barrières quand
il s'agit des secteurs technologiques et
industrielles on constate que souvent
les jeunes filles se censurent n'ose pas
faire des mathématiques de la physique
de la biologie et puis dans le cadre de
la réforme du collège
on a mis en place depuis deux ans le
parcours à venir et on essaye de mettre
en place des actions pour montrer un
petit peu la diversité des métiers le
temps d'un après-midi les collégiennes
de la clé saint-pierre à elancourt ont
pu échanger avec des professionnels des
techniciennes et ingénieurs là elles ont
directement les personnes avec
lesquelles peuvent parler et en plus là
aujourd'hui des personnes qui habitent
et l'encours des personnes qui
sont allés à l'école alors et l'encours
des personnes assez proches les
professionnels membre également de
l'association elles bougent partager
leurs propres expériences en tant que
femme avec les jeunes filles de
troisième quand on aime son travail on
trouve un compromis
voilà moi j'aime beaucoup on travaille
et j'aime beaucoup mes enfants j'en ai 3
est donc en bas je concilie du mieux
possible c'est un peu un puzzle
permanent un équilibre instable mais ça
marche très bien
cet atelier d'information était proposée
sur la base du volontariat
l'occasion d'avoir des réponses aux
inquiétudes des jeunes à l'image de
camille passionné de mathématiques qui
aimerait faire un travail dans les
sciences
je pensais qu'il y avait il y avait
beaucoup de temps de travail
alors qu'on peut aussi diminuer un peu
le temps de travail pour avoir la
famille des activités tout ça en france
seulement 21 % des femmes sont en poste
en tant qu'ingénieur plus de cent
cinquante mille personnes sont atteintes
du sida en france le sida c'est le
syndrome d'immunodéficience acquise
cette maladie causée par le vih virus de
l'immunodéficience humaine touche
principalement les cellules essentielles
de notre système immunitaire et pour
parler de la prévention et des actions
menées autour de cette pathologie nous
recevons jérôme andré directeur de la
chef prévention bonsoir bonsoir
alors on va commencer avec ce chiffre 79
% des jeunes entre 15 et 24 ans estiment
être bien informés sur le vih mais c'est
une baisse selon un sondage de l'ifop
bilan 10 et les adolescents de 15 à 17
ans sont principalement concernées
comment on peut remédier c'est justement
à ce manque d'information alors
justement donc il ya un vrai problème
aujourd'hui donc notamment chez les
jeunes chez les moins de 25 ans ce sont
les moins de 25 ans qui se contaminent
le plus et les plus de 50 ans on le voit
en réalité le souci qui se pose c'est
qu'il y à une désinformation qui est
fait depuis plusieurs années
c'est pour ça que effectivement des
structures associatives dont vivent
health care donc pour un labo pharma et
sida info service donc et hf préhension
se mobilisent sur ce qu'on va appeler
les fake news
2 comment est ce constat et et qu'on se
contaminent parce qu'en réalité par
exemple vous avez encore lee
et du chikungunya qui transporte du sang
le moustique et c'est donc les gens
pensent que on peut être contaminé par
le virus du sida simplement en
embrassant quelqu'un s'en plaint
simplement en buvant un verre d'eau
juste après lui ou encore par le fameux
moustiques qu'il y est pour rien donc on
voit qu'il ya une désinformation parce
que l'information ça reste le pouvoir
est en fait les jeunes ne s'empare pas
de cela il y a donc de moins en moins de
prévention qui est fait dans les lycées
et les cfa et nous on le voit bien quand
on dépiste sur les universités et
notamment par exemple saint quentin en
yvelines versailles où l'ensemble des
universités qu'on a en ile de france
on a de plus en plus de jeunes qui sont
séropositifs
et ça pour le coup ça pose un vrai
problème alors parlons-en justement de
la prévention par notamment du principal
mode de transmission du virus et les
rapports sexuels quels conseils vous
pouvez donner qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
justement pour éviter de via les
rapports sexuels d'être contaminés alors
effectivement donc l'utilisation du
préservatif ça reste quand même l'outil
principal que tout le monde peut
utiliser donc on en trouve en pharmacie
on en trouve dans des distributeurs on
en trouve dans les associations et même
en supermarché c'est pour ça que hf
prévention a sorti une application qui
s'appelle tubes pour trouver un
préservatif mais aussi les lieux de
dépistage
en france on le rappellera jamais assez
c'est important de mettre le préservatif
mais c'est aussi important de pouvoir
donc se dépister régulièrement grâce à
cette application vous géolocaliser vous
pouvez trouver les préservatifs qu'ils
soient gratuits ou payants autour de
vous alors justement reparler des
préservatifs avant de parler du
dépistage
à ce propos la mise de la santé agnès
buzyn a annoncé ce mardi 27 novembre le
remboursement des préservatifs prescrit
par un médecin ou un gynécologue ou une
sage femme avec une prise en charge à 60
% par la sécurité sociale est ce que
c'est une bonne solution
beaucoup vont vous dire que c'est une
bonne solution nous c'est pas notre cas
on aurait préféré que les préservatifs
soient donnés gratuitement dans les
pharmacies mais aussi dans les centres
commerciaux
parce qu'effectivement donc pourquoi
aller chez le médecin pour avoir une
ordonnance se faire rembourser à 60%
nombreuses de jeunes n'ont pas forcément
donc
mutuelle et non pourront pas donc
compenser le souci qui se pose avec
cette mesure c'est que c'est une vraie
mesure importante au niveau du
préservatif donc tant mieux c'était
réclamé par les associations depuis des
années on aurait bien aimé que ce soit
100% et on aurait bien aimé que ça ne
passe pas sûr de la médicalisation parce
que pour le coup c'est un peu compliqué
je trouve d'aller voir son médecin pour
lui demander des capotes alors qu'il
aurait fallu simplement aller en
pharmacie et demandé au pharmacien des
préservatifs et que le pharmacien puisse
donner des boîtes gratuite puisque
effectivement donc ces boîtes sont en
plus c'est pas pour tous les
préservatifs c'est uniquement pour la
marque heden qui a été donc qui a
remporté le marché de l'état mais on ne
dira jamais assez il existe tout un
panel de préservatifs adapté à la fois
en taille en morphologie et c est en
réalité
exactement il y a donc tout un tas de
préservatifs qui existent s'en était
bien que ce soit beaucoup plus large et
le souci qui se pose c'est aussi donc
sur le préservatif féminin puisque la la
mesure de la ministre c'est uniquement
sur le préservatif masculin
il aurait été bien de faire le même
effort sur le fémidon donc le
préservatif féminin l'autre prévention
là où vous communiquer beaucoup aussi
c'est sur le dépistage et il ya
plusieurs possibilités de dépistage
aujourd'hui exactement alors hf
prévention réalise 10 mille dépistages
donc par an en ile de france c'est
colossal
et effectivement on dépiste
principalement dans les universités les
centres commerciaux et les choeurs de
cité on se rend bien compte que le
dépistage doit être beaucoup plus donc
massif
il y a aussi les centres de dépistage
anonyme et gratuit
que vous pouvez donc retrouver dans
l'application tube il y a également donc
les laboratoires privés parce que les
médecins généralistes et là pour le coup
c'est leur rôle peuvent prescrire donc
des ordonnances pour aller donc en
laboratoire pour se faire dépister
et puis depuis deux ans trois ans de
deux ans et demi trois ans il existe les
autotests hélas pour le coup c'est une
vraie révolution parce que autant
jusqu'à présent on avait besoin de
quelqu'un pour se faire dépister autant
maintenant avec les autotests santé on a
la possibilité de se dépister chez soi
soi même donc du coup vous pouvez aller
en pharmacie ça coûte une vingtaine de
vous allez donc à demander un autotest
vih et vous allez pouvoir dans le faire
vous-même votre test directement à la
maison
à noter qu'en 2017 73 mille personnes
ont eu recours à cette auto test
parlons maintenant de quand on découvre
qu'on est séropositif près de 6000
personnes découvrent en moyenne chaque
année
qui sont ces héros peu qu'elles sont
séropositives d'après les chiffres de
santé publique france en 2017-2018 28%
des personnes ont été diagnostiqués
séropositifs avec un stade avancé
oui alors déjà expliquez-nous ce que
c'est un stade avancé et en quoi cette
situation est alarmante
ce sont en fait des gens qui enfin qui
s'ignoraient séropositifs et qui du coup
sont allés vers le stade de la maladie
sida aujourd'hui on ne meurt plus du
sida
à une seule condition c'est qu'on soit
dépistée et traitée si effectivement
donc les gens ont un traitement est bien
effectivement ils peuvent vivre pas
aussi bien qu'une personne qui est sans
traitement puisqu'il ya tout un tas
d'effets indésirables mais je dirais que
plus on va dépister quelqu'un tôt plus
il va gagner en durabilité c'est à dire
qu'il va pouvoir effectivement avoir
donc une qualité de vie qui restera tout
de même préservé le souci qui se pose
avec ces gens qui s'ignore tout le
travail de chef prévention c'est d'aller
chercher justement ses gencives qui
s'ignore c'est qu'on les découvre
séropositifs après plusieurs années donc
ils ont eu le temps effectivement
puisque eux mêmes ne le savais pas ils
ont eu le temps de contaminer d'autres
personnes
et puis effectivement ils sont à
proximité du stade sida qui fait que
comme il bascule dans le stade sida ils
peuvent en mourir
donc elle est là la problématique à la
fois sur le fait de ne pas connaître son
statut sérologique est de ne pas pouvoir
bénéficier des médicaments et en même
temps de contaminer d'autres personnes
et puis de mourir donc du virus du sida
on arrive bientôt au terme de cet
entretien une conclusion sur où on sont
les recherches au niveau des alors il a
le rire il est de fait que news sur les
recherches puisque vous allez entendre
que le vaccin a été trouvé et qu'on est
prêt à trouver le vaccin etc
je continue à dire et c'est important de
le rappeler le vaccin n'existe pas à ce
jour donc seul effectivement les moyens
de réduction des risques il n'y a pas
que le préservatif il ya tout un tas
d'autres panels
donc 2 pour réduire les risques de
contamination mais en réalité pour
l'instant le vaccin n'existe pas et je
continue aussi à dire qu'il est
important que chacun se sente concerné
parce qu'on a énormément de jeunes
qu'ils sont hétérosexuels en couple
première relation sexuelle et qui sont
pour le coup séropositifs alors si vous
souhaitez donner parce que finalement
l'accompagnement que vous faites vous
achève prévention et puis la recherche
est financée par des dons et les dont on
peut les faire sur le site dont 2.6
d'action point org le site s'affiche en
bas de l'écran
jérôme andré merci d'avoir accepté notre
réputation donc je rappelle que vous
êtes directeur de hf prévention passer
un excellent week-end merci vous en avez
l'habitude chaque vendredi dans l'hebdo
nous revenons sur les événements qui ont
fait l'histoire des yvelines et de saint
quentin avec notre rubrique ça s'est
passé un voyage dans le temps signés
wilfried richy
[Musique]
elle fait rêver toute l'équipe de france
250 mètres de long sur 8 mètres de large
et avec une pente plus importante
qu'ailleurs de 44 degrés la piste du
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
permettra aux cyclistes de faire tomber
les records du monde et c'est aussi dans
sa composition même que ce bois venu
tout droit de sibérie délivre ses
secrets là la particularité d'être une
essence très dur de croître très
lentement et donc d'être très peu soumis
aux variations d'hydrométrie c'est un
des matériaux qui permet aussi d'avoir
le plus de rendement
de restituer l'énergie des coureurs et
ce qui est très important pour pouvoir
gagner de la vitesse et des kilomètres
dans la configuration compétition près
de 5000 spectateurs pourront garnir les
gradins et assister à d'autres
événements sportifs ou musicaux
cette structure unique abritera
également le nouveau siège de la
fédération française de cyclisme
depuis quelques semaines les deux rampes
de départ de l'arenh de bmx et le
traçage des bosses sont sortis de terre
les sportifs seront hébergés sur place
dans ce bâtiment juste en face de
l'entrée principale
tout cela pour un investissement total
de 68 millions d'euros
l'ouverture est prévue le 13 janvier
2014 avant une inauguration officielle
le 30 qui verra le remake de la finale
de vitesse par équipes des derniers jeux
olympiques entre la france et la grande
bretagne
[Musique]
on passe tout de suite au résumé de
l'actualité de la semaine
[Musique]
un portail de signalement des violences
sexuelles a été lancée mardi 27 novembre
au commissariat de guyancourt des
ministres et des secrétaires d'état dont
le ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner étaient présents pour
l'occasion
un reportage de michael et demi d'euros
ne rien laisser passer c'est le message
qu'ont voulu transmettre quatre membres
du gouvernement ce mardi matin au
commissariat de guyancourt
christophe castaner marlène schiappa
laurent lyonnaise et nicole belloubet
sont venus inaugurer un portail de
signalement des violences sexuelles et
sexistes une plateforme ouverte 24
heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 pour qu'on
puisse libérer la parole pour au fond
réussir cette exigence continuum de
sécurité qui va de la prévention par l'
écoute l'accueil la procédure et la
sanction
autant de sujets sur lequel nous devons
offrir à chaque victime
les moyens de se faire entendre en 2010
est en france plus d'un million de
femmes ont été confrontées à une
situation de harcèlement au travail ou
dans les espaces publics
ce service gratuit et ouvert à tous aura
pour but de les dénoncer
quand vous êtes témoin d'un cambriolage
vous appelez la police ou la gendarmerie
quand vous avez connaissance d'une
violences sexistes et sexuelles votre
devoir de citoyen c'est d'appeler la
police ou la gendarmerie où désormais de
vous connecter à cette plate forme de
signalement des violences sexistes et
sexuelles au commissariat de guyancourt
c'est ce policier un psychologue vont
veiller à traiter ces demandes au niveau
national les victimes pourront dialoguer
sous la forme d'un chat avec les agents
elle sera sur une page avec un message
automatique lui indique bonjour comment
puis-je vous aider pour qu'elles ne se
sentent pas seuls devant sa page blanche
et elle pourra alors libérer sa parole
sur sur le vécu sur des violences
sexuelles ou ou sexistes qu'elle aurait
pu voir ou non elle aurait pu être
victime est un opérateur ou une
opératrice lui répondra en cas de forte
fréquentation du chat des effectifs
supplémentaires pourraient être recrutés
dans les prochains mois ce sera le
laboratoire mondial de recherche et
développement du groupe atos et
l'entreprise a choisi les
clayes-sous-bois comme site
d'implantation le pdg du groupe thierry
breton la présidente de la région ile de
france valérie pécresse et
plusieurs élus aux yvelinois ont
participé marty 27 novembre à la pose de
la première pierre de ce futur bâtiment
pour développer des projets innovants
regarder le site atos des
clayes-sous-bois futur lieu de
développement des ordinateurs du futur
cette société leader international de la
transformation digitale a lancé la
construction de son laboratoire mondial
de recherches et développement
un espace de 8000 mètres carrés près de
500 ingénieurs des travaux focaliser sur
l'informatique quantique à travers le
programme
atos quantum on commence à réfléchir
alors informatique dit quantique c'est à
dire utiliser un concept totalement
disruptif pour permettre aux futurs
ordinateurs de demain
accélérer de façon tout à fait
considérable leur puissance de calcul
mais c'est aussi un lieu qui nous permet
d'avoir beaucoup de compétences dans le
monde académique mais aussi parmi tous
les jeunes qui se forment les beaucoup
de compétences la région ile-de-france a
investi 5 millions d'euros sur ce
programme de recherche
un projet au coeur des territoires de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et de paris
saclay l'ordinateur quantique c'est
l'ordinateur du futur c'est la
technologie d'après c'est celle qui va
complètement transformer l'informatique
demain alors à tous a beaucoup hésité et
la région a considéré que c'était un
investissement totalement stratégique
nous devons avec les meilleurs dans ces
domaines c'est pour ça qu'il ne fallait
pas que le centre de recherche d'atos
partent en province et encore moins à
l'étranger et la région s'est fortement
mobilisée nous sommes 13 heures
aujourd'hui de cette décision
c'est une très bonne nouvelle bien
entendu pour le tout les yvelines et
bien entendu notamment saint quentin en
yvelines qui est directement impliqué
dans tous les projets avec la qualité
des entreprises que vous avez avec 13
milliards de chiffre d'affaires à tous
poursuit son ambition mondiale
ce nouveau laboratoire devrait ouvrir
courant 2020 la quatrième édition du
festival du film documentaire 50 1 se
poursuit ce week end au programme samedi
1er décembre à 13h30 à l'ugc skywest la
diffusion des deux épisodes de l'odyssée
interstellaire vous pouvez opter aussi
pour le film télescope intérieur réalisé
en collaboration avec l'astronaute
thomas pesquet
c'est à 18h30 au ciné cette des longs
cours puis dimanche de décembre le
document de pierre-emmanuel le golf le
golf pardon 16 lever de soleil revient
sur l' aventure de thomas pesquet dans
la station spatiale internationale
c'est à 16 heures au ciné cette avant la
remise des prix prévue à 18h30 pour
clôturer le festival
la campagne d'hiver des restos du coeur
s'est ouverte cette semaine quinze mille
bénéficiaires de se rendre dans les 27
centres des yvelines marylène iapichino
a suivi cette première journée à trappes
reportage les bras chargés et le sourire
aux lèvres les bénévoles du centre des
restos du coeur de trappes s'affairent
aujourd'hui s'ouvre la campagne d'hiver
tout doit être prêt pour la première
distribution de l'après midi aujourd'hui
on est reparti voilà donc il va y avoir
les gens qui sont venus s'inscrire la
semaine dernière et puis des tas de
familles qui sont pas venus et qui vont
venir en corse après midi donc ça va
être chargé le centre est ouvert trois
jours par semaine les lundi mardi et
jeudi
la matinée consacrée à la réception des
produits récoltés dans les grandes
surfaces
il faut ensuite les trier et les mettre
en place un travail qui nécessite de la
main d'oeuvre
nous avons des compléments du complément
donc ça peut être des gâteaux que ces
dames sont en train de préparer donc
elles elles trient les des paquets et
elle prépare pour faire des petits
sachets pour que chaque personne
accueillie plus avoir un petit peu de
gâteaux d'accord justement drilles au
national a elle même bénéficiaire est
venu prêter main forte
après une visite et une explication du
fonctionnement des lieux la jeune
albanaise arrivé en france il ya quatre
ans est rapidement mis à contribution
voilà donc un peu le centre ben écoute
je te souhaite la bienvenue
et puis merci de le proposer de nous
aider voilà plus de 400 en famille
qu'ils soient accueillis
voilà donc ça pour moi très important
d'essayer d'avoir des gens qui viennent
nous aider même que ça soit une matinée
une après midi
voilà chaque bénévole est bienvenu chez
nous l'après-midi le local prêté par la
municipalité sur mon plis sabrina
bertrand vit seule avec trois enfants
elle vient chaque semaine et connaît
bien l'équipe trappistes des restos pour
moi c'est comme une famille
ou deuxième famille sont bien quand je
viens ici ça m'évite de rester tout seul
isolé comme chaque bénéficiaire à la
temps d'être appelé par un bénévole avec
lequel elle va remplir son caddie en
fonction du nombre de personnes dans le
foyer elle a droit un certain nombre de
points des points à dépenser pour chaque
famille de produits des légumes jusqu'à
la viande en passant par les produits
laitiers au total chaque bénéficiaire
repart avec un repas par jour et par
personne
six jours par semaine au revoir c'est
une première étape pour le chantier de
la nationale 10 lancé cet été au mois de
juillet elle concerne les réseaux d'eaux
usées et pluviales des travaux dont les
premières réflexions remonte à 20 ans en
arrière à noter que chaque jour 80 mille
véhicules y circulent
le point sur le chantier avec mélanie
poker père que le projet d'aménagement
concernera un passage souterrain pour
les piétons le souhait de sept
trappistes verra bientôt le jour
mais c'est la nationale 10 qui sera
souterraine elle les travaux ont débuté
l'été dernier au niveau de l'île de
loisirs des travaux de dévoiement
préalable à l'enfouissement
donc ces techniques à 130 chaires
l'occurrence comme vous pouvez le voir
c'est du forage à la tarière voilà donc
le forage à la tarière ça consiste à
passer une telle formation d'un sous sol
et de faire une esclave à sion avec une
tarière tout simplement un chantier
préalables à la construction du tunnel
une première étape d'un montant de plus
de 4 millions d'euros
ces réseaux reprennent tout simplement
une fois leur dévoiement fait les
réseaux d'origine qui était de part et
d'autre de la nationale 10 pour aller
pour notamment pour le pluvial à la base
de saint quentin en yvelines
sur les temps intermédiaires c'est juste
un dévoiement avec quelques
améliorations on profite par là par là
par là même pour remettre à niveau
certains réseaux mais l'objet du
chantier c'est le dévoiement des réseaux
pour garder ce système gravitaire
nécessaire à l'écoulement des eaux de
part et d'autre de la nationale 10 cette
partie du chantier doit prendre fin en
août 2019
la prochaine étape l'enfouissement de la
nationale 10 3 ans de travaux et 100
millions d'euros seront nécessaires
[Musique]
arrivé largement en tête avec 59,1 pour
cent des voix francis chouat le maire
d'evry devient le nouveau député de la
première circonscription de l'essonne
il remplace l'ancien premier ministre
manuel valls qui a décidé d'être
candidat pour devenir maire de barcelone
en espagne
reportage de nos confrères de via grand
paris c'est le maire d'evry francis
chouraqui occupe désormais le poste de
député de la première circonscription de
l'essonne à la place de manuel valls
française choix obtient 59,1 pour cent
des voix l'homme qui se revendique
officiellement sans étiquette a profité
du soutien de la république en marche et
de plusieurs élus
une force selon lui qu'il compte bien
maintenir sur les bancs de l'assemblée
nationale
j'ai accepté des soutiens dans le
soutien de la république en marche mais
aussi d'autres soutiens l'immense
majorité des élus socialistes de la
circonscription et donc ça me donne une
force
c'est la liberté permettez moi de voir
avec les amis mes collègues maires
l'ensemble de celles et ceux qui ont
mené cette campagne
quel est le meilleur dispositif pour
concilier deux choses ma liberté et la
nécessité de faire avancer les sujets
face à lui
farida amrani candidate de la france a
soumise ne recueille que 39,9 % des voix
exprimées
celle qui a souhaité limiter ses
déclarations aux réseaux sociaux
regrette le fort taux d'abstention
atteignant les 80 2%
l'abstention lors d'une élection
législative partielle et une haie et est
habituellement fait aimer ce qui l'est
moins c'est dans cette proportion en
tout cas sur notre territoire
cela veut dire que le clan t le
clientélisme et les petits arrangements
honte en abyme et notre circonscription
les dirigeants politiques locaux portent
une grande responsabilité de ce dégoût
de la politique qui s'exprime
aujourd'hui avec l'élection de francis
chouat à la députation de la première
circonscription de l'essonne
l'agglomération grand paris sud doit
élire un nouveau président et la
nouvelle commune d'evry courcouronnes
doit choisir un nouveau maire
pour cette dernière élection stéphane
beaudet actuel maire de courcouronnes
serait pressenti ce numéro merci de nous
avoir suivis retour de l'information
lundi à 18h dans le 7-8 journal présenté
par grégory canal et d'ici là à passer
un excellent week end
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh